i'm very comfortable you know my
partners with the show everybody's ready
wendy williams speaks out about her
ongoing absence from her daytime talk
show and reveals when she'll return to
the small screen we've got a lot to talk
about the 57 year old tv personality
opened up in a pre-recorded phone
interview with good morning america on
thursday and despite rumors about her
health and her mental well-being wendy
insists she's doing great
health is very well and um i actually
had a few appointments
you know i'm 57 now and i have the mind
and body of a 25 year old
of course this comes as a string of
guest hosts have been filling in on the
wendy williams show for the past eight
months after initially delaying the
season 13 premiere
first revealing the talk show host
tested positive for covid19 then
announcing she was struggling with
ongoing health issues due to her graves
disease and thyroid disorder
my graves disease is it how do my eyes
look how do my eyeballs look beautiful
and not too big thank you thank you
that's taken care of but as you know it
takes at least a year to level out the
thyroid so
you know my thyroid medication is still
being leveled but i feel i feel good
but wendy maintains the reason for the
delay has nothing to do with her health
but rather she has some things she needs
to work out
in fact wendy says she's ready to get
back to it and even gives a timeline
well
give me give me about
three months i
i there are private things that i have
to deal with and then i'll be ready to
come back
and be free and ready to do my thing and
if you still aren't convinced wendy
doubles down and teases that we haven't
seen the last of her on our tv yet keep
watching because i'm going to be back on
the wendy's show
bigger and brighter than ever
it's a sentiment wendy first shared last
month when giving an update to concerned
fans on instagram
like i want to be all i can be
and then get back to new york
and
get on down with the wendy williams show
shortly after that sherry shepherd who's
filled in for wendy many times announced
that she will be debuting a new talk
show during wendy's time slot in the
fall
but the comedian made it clear she's not
replacing wendy there have been all
these crazy stories online about me
replacing wendy and i am here to tell
you that that is not true
because no one can replace the queen
nobody
in a statement to deadline the
co-presidents of debar mercury the
show's producer and distributor said
they are open to reviving wendy's show
if she's interested following her
recovery
of course this all comes amid the tv
personality's battle with her bank over
control of her fortune
last month wendy fired back at wells
fargo strenuously denying claims she is
struggling with her mental health after
the bank alleged she is an incapacitated
person who needs a guardianship well you
know when people want control of their
accounts they say anything including
something crazy like that about me they
saying that i need somebody to handle my
account
and i don't want that
i want
all my money i want to see all my money
that i've worked hard for my entire life
my entire life e.t previously spoke to
attorney mitra ahirian who does not rep
either party they had some concerns over
her ability to make financial decisions
and they froze all her assets so she
cannot do the simplest things like
pay her bills they really need evidence
that she is unsound mind i don't lie i
don't cheat and i don't steal
i am an honest
hard-working person
[Music]
you